we're asked to solve and graph the
system of equations here and just as a
bit of review solving a system of
equations really is means figuring out
the x and y value that will satisfy both
of these equations and one way to do it
is to use one of the equations to solve
for either the X or the Y and then
substitute for that value in the other
ones that make sure that you're making
use of both constraints so let's start
with this bottom equation right here so
we have Y minus X is equal to 5 it's
pretty straightforward to solve for y
here we just have to add X to both sides
of this equation so add X and so the
left-hand side these X's cancel out the
negative x and the positive x and we're
left with Y is equal to 5 plus X y is
equal to 5 plucks plus X now the whole
point of me doing that is now we can
anytime we see a Y in the other equation
we can we can replace it with a 5 plus X
so the other equation was during this
orange color 9x plus 3y is equal to 15
this second equation told us if we just
rearranged it that Y is equal to 5 plus
X so we can replace Y in the second
equation with 5 Plex plus X that make
sure we're making use of both
constraints so let's do that we're going
to replace Y with 5 plus X so this 9x
plus 3y equals 15 becomes 9x plus 3
times y the second equation says y is 5
plus X so we're going to put 5 plus X
there instead of a Y 3 times 5 plus X is
equal to 15 is equal to 15 and now we
can just solve for x we get 9x plus 3
times 5 is 15 plus 3 times X is 3x is
equal to 15 so we can add the 9x and the
3x so we get 12 X plus 15 12 X plus 15
is equal to 15 is equal to 15 now we
could subtract 15 from both sides
subtract 15 from both sides just
so you get only X terms on the left hand
side these guys cancel each other out
and you're left with 12 X is equal to 0
now you divide both sides by 12 and you
get X is equal to 0 over 12 or X is
equal to 0 so let me scroll down a
little bit so X is equal to 0 X is equal
to 0 now if x equals to 0 what is y well
we could substitute into either one of
these equations up here if we substitute
x equals 0 in this first equation you
get 9 times 0 plus 3y is equal to 15 or
that's just 0 so you get 3y is equal to
15 divide both sides by 3 you get Y is
equal to 15 over 3 or 5y is equal to 5
and we can test that that also satisfies
this equation
y 5 minus 0 is also equal to 5 so the
value so the value X is equal to I'll do
this in green X is equal to 0 Y is equal
to 5 satisfies both of these equations
so we've done the first part let's do
the second part where we're asked to
graph it and the second equation is
pretty straightforward to graph we
actually ended up putting it in MX plus
B form right there and actually let me
rewrite it let me just switch the X and
the 5 so it really isn't that MX plus B
form so Y is equal to X plus 5 so it's
y-intercept is 5 1 2 3 4 5 and it's
slope is 1 right there's a 1 implicitly
being multiplied or the X is being
multiplied by 1 so it looks like this
the line let me see how well I can draw
it the line will look like that has a
slope of 1 you move back 1 you go down 1
you move forward 1 you go up 1 that's a
pretty good job so that right here is
this equation now let's graph that top
equation and we just have to put it in
MX plus B form or slope-intercept form
and I'll do that in green so we have 9x
plus 3y is equal to 15 one
simplification we can do from the right
off right from the get-go is every
number here's the
visible by three so let's just divide
everything by three to make things
simpler so we get 3x plus y is equal to
five now we can subtract 3x from both
sides we subtract 3x from both sides we
are left with y is equal to negative 3x
plus five so that's what this first
equation gets turned into if you put it
in slope-intercept form y is equal to
negative 3x plus five so if you were to
graph it the y-intercept is 5 0 5 and
then it's slope is negative 3 so you
move 1 in the x-direction you move down
3 in the y-direction
move 2 you would move down 6 2 4 6 move
two you go to 4 6 so this line is going
to look something like this it's going
to look something something like that
right there and as you can see the
solution to this system is the point of
intersection of these two lines it's the
combination of x and y that satisfy both
of these remember this pink line or this
red line is all of the X's and Y's that
satisfy this equation y minus X is equal
to 5 this green line is all of the X's
and Y's or all the combinations of them
that satisfy this first equation now the
one x and y combination that satisfies
both is their point of intersection and
we figured it out algebraically using
substitution that happens at X is equal
to 0 Y is equal to 5 X is equal to 0
this is the x-axis Y is equal to 5 right
there